is
i'd like to ask him what the audition
process was like and how of all the
people across the world who got head
hunted for a hbo show
um the audition process was pretty it
was bizarre in the sense that it was it
was very uh unoriginal it was uh
it was like a five minute audition i
actually had to come back from irish
college we were trying to figure out the
name of the grind school that they have
in kerry or something i was there in
fifth year and uh i got bruno parker
that was it
on the wall i fought
so i was there and uh i think i got a
call or an email or something about an
audition for a tv show and i i was like
debating whether to to go up to dublin
for it but i decided to do it and uh
yeah went to the audition was like five
five minutes long did like a short scene
it was the scene the first scene i was
in actually when i'm confronting rob
stark for the first time and uh
yeah and then they just said well done
and i left and i completely put out my
mind
and then a few months later i got the
call so it's a complete surprise to be
honest it wasn't very sensational
and uh
yeah that's the kind of banal story so
from the beginning you knew you were
auditioning for joffrey
yes i did yeah did you know the sort of
reputation he has from the books
well i mean not really i didn't know i
didn't know how much people hated the
character
i knew you know i i read the first book
and i read all the you know synopsis
online and stuff so i knew he was he
wasn't
the the nicest character all around uh
but i didn't i
i didn't really gauge the reaction of
the book readers before the show came
out so i didn't know
yeah the kind of vitriol people had for
the character until
and so if you weren't starring and it
would be the sort of show that you'd be
interested in yourself
it's hard to say actually it's hard to
say because i uh i'm ashamed to say i
don't watch the show myself um
just because it's it's kind of awkward
looking at yourself uh acting and
your friends like acting as well um
so uh it was it's not in that respect
but i don't know
so uh today what has been your uh
favorite scene to film
that's a div yeah
any action emerald i have seen
um
it's hard to say
it might be a bit of a cop-out answer
but i do enjoy filming every scene uh
well there was that scene yeah i suppose
the the one involving two uh
ladies of the night
that uh as one can imagine was rather
awkward to film but
you know a story to tell my
grandchildren when they
get a bit older
yeah future in-laws yeah yeah
so um another question i've robbed from
reddit is there anything that joffrey
wouldn't do
he wouldn't do yeah in in his life um
i don't know
i mean apart from yeah because he can
he's he's kind of he can do whatever he
wants you know so
uh i suppose do something
for the poor perhaps
yeah
he'd never really do that unless he's
forced to you by his mother or somewhere
the like yeah
not the most altruistic fella
moving on from that uh obviously you're
nothing like your character in real life
but what i wanted to ask you is sir
that's subjective
uh something i want to ask you is there
anybody on uh on the set that you'd
actually
compare very like to their character
there are actually yeah there are a few
i mean like peter dinklage would be
quite similar to his character tyrion in
the sense that he's very kind of like
he's very witty and he's got a very dry
sense of humor and he's also very
intelligent
so in that sense i'd i'd compare the two
um
who else i mean certainly charles dance
who plays tyron uh tywin in like just in
real life he walks into the room and
he's like this
building of a man he just said hello
darling how are you today and he's like
i love you
so uh he's he's quite kind of
intimidating and quite he's like he he
uh oozes confidence just like his
character tywin so those two people i'd
say would be quite similar to their
characters
and uh something i've been fairly
concerned about but rumor has it that
you're considering stopping mainstream
acting after uh the game thrones has
finished oh your part in game thrones is
finished
uh why would that be that's true yeah um
i mean it really comes down to just a
nice
kind of driving as much enjoyment as i
did from acting as i used to you know i
started acting when i was ace and really
really loved this you know and all i
wanted to be was an actor when i grew up
but for some reason i don't know it it
became kind of a bit uh mechanical and
less uh less kind of
passion passionate for me when i started
game of thrones i don't think it's got
anything to do with the way they film it
but
i think when uh when it became less of a
recreation and more of a more of a
profession it kind of put more pressure
on the acting itself and
made it a tiny bit less enjoyable yeah
just going a bit back and forth i just
like to go back to joffrey and there's
two questions i wanted to ask and uh the
internet really wants to ask you as well
and it's which part of yourself in real
life would you relate the most
it's difficult
i suppose not the incest
yeah
yeah
i'm trying to think
uh
well i am technically a king i'm the
king of ireland i don't know if you
if you've got that memo
uh no um
i don't think i really relate to
anything he does to be honest i mean his
main kind of hobbies are going out
hunting and that kind of thing and
i've never really i do a bit of fishing
i don't know
if that counts as shooting a boar with
an arrow
yeah i fish therefore i'm like joffrey
yeah
um
um
what part would you most empathize with
with poor joffrey you know i think he's
found himself in a yeah well he's evil
at heart i think he's found himself in a
horrible position to be in i'd empathize
a lot with him to be honest uh
in everything he does because first of
all
i think in kind of a neuroscientific
level i don't think incest is great for
kind of the frontal lobe and
kind of moral centers so uh i empathize
it's not his fault uh in that sense that
he's kind of this malevolent uh king i
think it's partly a genetic thing and
then also it's a it's a contextual thing
in the sense that you know his father
didn't really love him and his mother
was overprotective and he was told from
day one that he could do whatever he
wanted so it's kind of you know if
anyone here if they were put into that
context i think they turn out like
joffrey perhaps so
myself included so i think i can
empathize him in that sense that i
wouldn't say he's he's inherently
immoral or evil but simply the product
of his of his setting in this context
yeah um
um
well i can tell you i can tell you that
i think that he has that he has an
inkling you know
um there's a scene i think in in season
two or three in which he kind of
confronts his mother about and he's kind
of like does
um
does robert have any other sons or
daughters that i know about um
that i don't know about so i think he
does have an inkling um but as far as i
know it's pretty unknown yeah
how you managed to be so despicable in
the show
yeah just
i don't know
it's a good question um
i mean a lot of it to be honest a lot of
it comes from the character itself you
know i think any
any actor worth their salt with the
really good writing and the
and
and the actors acting opposite you
create the character you know it's not
just it's not just your own
um ability uh
and also you know the the whole the
costume and the crown and
uh
it's not just it's not just the actor
that kind of creates the characters so
um i'm helped a lot
yeah either
there
yeah they have actually there's the dan
and dave the two creators of the show
love pranking the cast to get a real
kick out of this um i'm trying to think
uh well they did one to alfie allen i
think in the second season where they
wrote a scene in which his character
dies
and uh
uh they gave it to him and he was like
really really upset and i was like this
is [ __ ] you know i can't believe
this
it's like read the books for once you
know uh
so that's when um
there was one they did recently actually
on gwendolyn christie um who plays um
brienne
uh which is they they wrote incredible
like photoshop skills they they made up
a fake new york times article in which
uh it describes like her being really
rude to a fan and like it was all about
her being a [ __ ] in real life and stuff
and and like david the direct the the
creator was just scrolling down and i
was like
gwen what's up with this and she was
like i don't even remember i don't even
remember that
[ __ ] and she's like ringing up her
publicist and so it's very funny
so yeah
dan and dave are good for the other
pranks for sure
yeah
george rr yep does he have a big input
into the series i think he does yeah i
mean uh he does he writes i think he
writes one episode a season
i don't really work with him a huge man
he doesn't really come to set so much
but i think he really does have a big a
big influence on
just the kind of tone of the whole piece
i think he's an executive producer or
something like that so uh i i've only
met him once or twice um but he's a
really really nice man very uh very
unassuming and very jolly
in every way
um do you have any stories of an
experience where someone's failed to
distinguish between you
thankfully no no yeah thankfully not um
no everyone i mean yeah i i i
i get asked that sometimes and i'm
always kind of baffled the idea that
some people can't distinguish like
fiction from reality but i mean it's
never happened to me thankfully
so
no because if they did it kind of i'd be
in danger
yeah um
maybe even kit yeah yeah kiss yeah
because i've met him a few times he
seems like a really cool guy so i like
to act with him perhaps
but there's there's too many you know
you want to work with every actor on the
show there's too many characters
um
uh but he'd be one for sure yeah he
seems like a really nice guy even though
he broke his leg it's never heard about
that they had to delay filming fray just
because he drunkenly climbed his wall
after a night out and broke his leg
the muppet
was it as emotional for you as it was
for me when you killed nedstar
yeah
well first of all i'm sorry it was
emotional
um
second of all i did have to hold back
years well i was like no i don't want to
do it i tried to talk with the riders to
try and get the whole plot changed
what's that somebody else
somebody else do it or you know just put
them on a boat put them somewhere safe
they didn't buy us but uh i was pretty
torn up about it i must say yeah
yeah um
is that true
yeah it is true um
kind of not not that uh consciously so
to speak um but more the more and more i
acted uh the character i kind of
realized that there were similarities
between the two just i think because
there's similarities between the
characters you know they're both kind of
uh petulant and egotistical
and show-offy
and you know jacquin phoenix is just an
incredible actor so i suppose i look up
to him and that performance you know